Jim wrote to me hey David what was the
most difficult aspect of learning
English as a second language for you
okay very good question I did learn
English as a second language but very
early on so I spoke only Spanish until I
was about six years old and then I was
fully immersed in American English
school and within three or four months I
had caught up to the English level that
everybody in my class had but yet there
were still some things that remained as
the difficult thing so I'll tell you
what was difficult for me it might be
different if you're learning English as
an adult
number one the inconsistent pronounce
the pronunciation of like Oh ugh yes
where is through and tough end in the
same way but are pronounced completely
differently and use those letters
individually
none of those make those noise you
basically just have to know the words
and that's similar to Hebrew which I've
learned a little bit I'm not nearly as
proficient as I am in Spanish or English
where you just have to recognize words
especially because Hebrew is written
without vowels so from the context you
have to recognize oh this word that
might be made up of just four consonants
it means one of two three or four
different things based on the context
and the words around it so that was
really difficult with English there were
some names that were difficult for me
like I that the name Penelope was pen
elope
until freshman year of high school when
I finally met someone named Penelope and
then saw the name written I just didn't
know I thought it was pen elope and I
was of course sort of wondering I've
never heard that name said out loud but
I keep seeing it written it must be
panel oh I don't know so that was
difficult but that's really just more of
us what specific culture you're in and I
do think that there are some
pronunciation differences which to a
native speaker now I hear them but
initially I didn't so for example the
difference between someone's ear and
next year it's a very slight difference
for a non-native speaker and look for my
parents that's still something that they
don't really pronounce differently it's
just kind of a blend whether they're
saying someone's ear canal or New Year's
Day they pronounce it the exact same way
those types of nuances were kind of
difficult what about just the size of
ink
vocabulary because of course English is
a Germanic language yep takes a lot from
the Romance languages and of course it's
affected by the Norman conquest of 1066
as well natural so you know just like in
Spanish for example the word for problem
is what problema
and the word for issue well that depends
I know it's not a synonym it depends on
the on the situation it depends on the
situation but it would be a different
one okay well you're supposed to say the
same thing okay yeah it's the same word
to play a great example because I just
think the sheer amount of vocabulary in
English is is many times over what no no
I don't know it's I don't know if this
is why this happens but there are books
that I books that are translated to
English like for example Henning Mangal
is a now deceased crime fiction writer
from Sweden so I was reading his books
translated because I don't read Swedish
I would usually read them in English but
then eventually I said hey I should pick
up some of these in Spanish just to keep
up my Spanish reading and every single
time the Spanish language translation
had significantly more pages than the
English language translation and I
wonder and I don't know the answer I
should ask my mom who teaches Spanish
literature and Spanish language I wonder
if the reason for the much longer
translation into Spanish is that because
English has a larger vocabulary there
are many words and phrases that can be
translated more concisely because there
might be one word in English to describe
that idea whereas maybe in Spanish you
need a few words I don't know I'm
thinking out loud I think that's what it
is and also I mean you can't directly
translate things I mean you you put
something it's a Google Translate oh
yeah it come out in Spanish it's going
to be a lot longer of course but also
it's going to be incomprehensible to
someone who speaks that language maybe
so maybe so yeah although Google Google
Translate has gotten pretty good it's
really gotten pretty good there's also
so many irregular verb forms English in
English they're like you can't you're
sad like for past tense you can't just
add Edie to every single words no times
like that time again you know you told
us that you had bought in something and
even you as a native speaker of English
once made that mistake and we figured
out no I bought something I had bought
it I hadn't bought in it it was one of
my worst moments oh yeah well you and
you were also talking about botany
that's I think how you
get in the audience I think for the most
part believe that okay we've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today
on the bonus show we will be talking
about how letting kids sleep in could
save nine billion dollars a year we will
talk about zero waste stores putting
consumers on the front line in the fight
against packaging remember that orange
at Whole Foods that was wrapped in saran
wrap on a styrofoam tray or something
insane anyway we'll rehash that on the
bonus show and also this is a weird
story parents reportedly traveled from
India to help their son beat his wife a
very very strange and disturbing story
all of those stories and more on the
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership get signed up and get instant
access